tanbridge house secondary school in west
sussex
open only to vulnerable pupils and
children of key workers
it's much busier than during the first
lockdown with around 100 students
attending
last monday a day after boris johnson
said that schools were safe he ordered
them to close
and also announced that exams would be
cancelled the head teacher jules white
it's been a constant battle to keep up
it's been very difficult i think
everyone and every head teacher has
sympathy for the government and the
department for education
in these times of a pandemic but the
mixed messaging the inconsistent
messaging
change after change you tune after
u-turn has been very very difficult
to deal with head teachers we really
know what we're doing
we want our schools to be open where we
can we want to look after vulnerable
children we want to allow the parents of
critical workers you know they need to
work as well
but the goal posts they think to change
every five minutes we waste
time resource and energy it's so
difficult to manage and most of all
children and parents are not getting a
consistent message either
i mean i guess if you have more notice
then you could have invested more in
online learning made sure that the
laptops were there
made sure that the teachers were
equipped to provide it and as a result
you're having to scramble that's
absolutely right if you look at just
before christmas there was
the threat of legal action about schools
who were thinking about closing because
of public
health risks then over the christmas
myself and other head teachers
we really busted a gut to try and put in
place
math testing plans which were pretty
flawed in the first place
then just before we go back we then have
to
change and move towards children not
coming in and online learning
now at the moment just in the the last
week the secretary of state has said
we're going to trust teachers on exam
grades but at the same time
talks about having to use ofsted to come
and check out what we're doing is really
just
bewildering and almost impossible to
manage we know
our children we know our families and if
we're actually trusted to deliver
we will do we we really understand that
there is a crisis upon us
and we have to do everything we can to
make sure our schools are open
when it's safe to do so another big call
by the government this week was the
decision to cancel
exams i was quite interested in the
survey results it shows that
overwhelmingly people think the teachers
think that it's right to cancel exams
but actually some comprehensive
contingency plan should be in place
already so we should know what the
replacement assessment should be and
does that surprise you
we've been asking for contingency plans
and a plan
b for some time even before this latest
variant came into place there was a real
risk that children were missing too much
time in school to have a fair go at a
national exam
program yet here we are no plans have
been
announced going to consultation again we
all feel that this should have been in
place
it is a difficult problem i think at the
root of things
teachers will have to be trusted to give
fair grades
for all of the exams hopefully there can
be some sort of external
checking or moderation that may be a way
forward to give further confidence to
the system
but again we need to be consulted with
we need to be listened to
we actually know what we're doing and we
really hope that dfe and off well take
note of that and we avoid the crisis and
the fiasco of last summer i think is
everyone wants to trust teachers of
course but
at the same time you do you can't help
but think that if teachers have complete
control over what grades are given
we're going to see some pretty high
grades been given out
yes i think last year we saw some great
inflation i think we have to be
realistic about that i also think we
have to be realistic that
no system is going to be perfect we're
in the middle of a pandemic but teachers
will use proper professional judgment
perhaps we can use some form of
online testing or a window of external
assessment which is
fair to all students much more reduced
that might be a reference point
again we will do our absolute best to
treat every child
fairly and we don't actually want to
just give away
grades that's not what we're in the job
for we want to make sure that every
child whether they're in search of a
college place
a university place an apprenticeship is
given
the opportunity to do so in a fair way
a survey of a thousand head teachers
carried out by campaign group worth less
and shared with sophie ridge on sunday
found that 52 percent have
no confidence in the department for
education's decision-making
and 41 percent have hardly any only six
percent
are fairly confident and just one
percent feel confident
91 percent of head teachers said that
the government was right to cancel all
assessments for summer 2021
only 9 said that was the wrong decision
but 92 percent of heads said that
comprehensive contingency plans for
alternative grading systems should
already have been set out by the
department for education
simon liebers head of the exam's body of
course has been in the job just one week
quite a baptism of fire there is a plan
b um
my my my officials and the department
spent quite a lot of time
last year working that out in detail but
i think one's got to recognize that
there's a it's a sort of framework in a
sense because
plan b as it's implemented in january is
not going to be the same as plan b if
it's implemented because because exams
are
cancelled in maine and i think the other
thing to recognize is that at the end of
the day
um people need to feel that the results
are fair we need to have a proper
opportunity to consult with parents with
students with teachers with schools or
school organizations
how can you make sure whatever replaces
the exams
is fair and doesn't discriminate against
people from
less advantaged backgrounds um you would
be idle to pretend that's a
straightforward
um challenge clearly any sort of
arrangements do need to take account of
the fact that we've got a very wide
range of learning experiences that have
to be assessed and evaluated
i think there's going to be a big
challenge in terms of making sure that
the
um the the teacher assessed grades the
um the methods we use encompass that
range of learning but at the same time i
think they have to reflect
actual achievement and actual learning
some people have had an absolutely
appalling experience and lost masses of
learning
others have virtually been unimpacted
have you got any
ideas for how to make a fair assessment
system
it's already been been made clear that
the the system is going to be based on
teacher assessment the question then is
how you
make sure that teachers assess teacher
assessment is relatively consistent
across
the um the school network you've got to
deal with the reality that there are
perverse incentives there's quite a big
grade inflation last year there's lots
of potential for an even bigger grade
inflation
this year the reality is that exams
aren't always fair some pupils will have
had better education than others
some children will have personal
circumstances that mean they do less
well at school
but like with so many other things the
pandemic is taking
existing problems and exacerbating them
the prime minister hopes to reopen
schools after the february half term
that is now looking optimistic on
current evidence
2021 looks to be just as disruptive as
the year before
my piece on schools there well in
response the department for education
has sent
us a statement and this is it we know
this is a challenging time for schools
and pupils and that's why we're
launching a consultation with offcoal
next week
on the best options for alternatives to
exams to ensure
every young person gets a fair grade for
their work grades will be based on
teacher assessment and support will be
provided to ensure grades are awarded
fairly and
consistently every major public health
decision we've taken has been guided
by the best scientific and medical
advocate advice and we are working to
ensure
the best possible outcome for schools
and pupils